hey everyone it's sarah stanner sorry
and calm and in this video you're going
to see a demonstration on how to check
for clonus in our previous review we
talked about preeclampsia and - the
things that we stressed in that lecture
was that we needed to check for
hyperreflexia and clone a specifically
ankle clonise because if those two
things are present it indicates that our
central nervous system is really
stressed out and irritable and there's a
risk for seizures so let me show you how
to check for clonise and what a positive
result looks like first of all you want
to do is you want to have the patient's
setting and dangling their feet then
you're gonna take your hand and you're
going to support the lower leg that you
want to test and you are going to
dorsiflex
the foot so I pointed upwards quickly
and look for the response and then let
it go and that's a normal response that
would be a negative clonus a positive
clonus you do the same thing you're
gonna quickly dorsiflex the foot and
you're gonna look for its response a
positive response would be that the foot
starts to bounce or be at least three or
more times and that would be considered
a positive clonise okay so that is how
you check for clonise and don't forget
to check out our other reviews in this
maternity series